joining us now is valerie jarrett she
was a senior advisor to former president
barack obama valerie good morning
you've said there's nothing like thank
you anthony good morning
you said there's nothing like running
against somebody to know what it's like
to have them on your team
what do you think joe biden learned
about senator harris running against her
and why as you should as you say
would she make a terrific vice president
well look she was a formidable candidate
she has an incredible track record as
seasoned
public servant at the local state and
federal level
amazing experience serving on the
judiciary committee
doing her job by interrogating witnesses
also her service on the intelligence
community
committee gives her a perspective on
world affairs she will
have the gravitas to command respect not
just around the country
but around the world and i think as
people get to know this dynamic duel
they'll recognize that they are just the
right people to lead our country forward
as we come out of this dreadful pandemic
and try to rebuild our economy
a lot was made of the of the verbal
punch she threw during the debates about
bussing
uh at the former vice president and some
people in the biden camp were reportedly
stung by this how did they get past that
well i think vice president biden is a
bigger person than that
he's not thin skinned he's looking for
the person who can
share the responsibility of campaigning
together and then more importantly
leading our country
and so a minor skirmish like that isn't
going to trouble him
i mean i think back to president obama
selecting
hillary clinton a very worthy opponent
as his secretary of state
they're looking out for what's best for
their country and not letting their
you know fragile egos get in the way and
i think what president trump was saying
calling her
you know a nasty woman we don't use that
kind of language to describe
men and particularly women who are doing
their jobs she was running a campaign
she's interrogating witnesses
she's serving the people's interests and
i think the american people
will realize that and i know one thing
vice president biden
and senator harris are going to work
very hard to earn their trust
michelle miller here politics aside team
harris
is a considerable network judging from
just the tweets i saw yesterday from her
sorority sisters to her hbcu alum and
beyond
it seems so obama-esque she checks so
many boxes in representation
does she galvanize an energy that looks
or feels
similar to you
well look i think that she has broad
appeal and that obviously was very
attractive
to vice president biden i've seen her on
the campaign trail
she is both a indefatigable advocate
but she's also kind and gentle and has
wonderful moments of tenderness and i
think
that's also something that vice
president biden saw in her
valerie the senator harris has really
kind of been the front runner from the
beginning
i think in many people's eyes what does
it say to you about the state of the
democratic party
that the daughter of of immigrants from
from jamaica and from india
was kind of the conservative choice here
well you know what i think first of all
it is in a sense the american story
immigrants who come here who work hard
who raised their two daughters to think
that there were no limits to what they
could achieve
i think that's a story we will all look
up to i think about
the young girls and boys around the
country who will see a different vision
of what a vice president looks like and
the kind of leadership
that and perspective that she will bring
to not just the party but the country
we heard what president trump had to say
a lot of people are
waiting to see how the senator responds
what do you think she'll say
i think she will go big as she always
does her focus is really on
talking directly to the american people
there have been a lot of barbs that have
been sent her way
and she just brushes them off she
recognizes that that's the nature of the
game but i will say this to you michelle
there's a group of women that sent a
letter to the media which i know you all
say
saw saying that we're going to have her
back you're going to hear more today
they're going to be organizations such
as time's up that i serve on the board
of
who for the next 83 days and beyond will
be looking out
for those uh indications of
discrimination
that are just simply not acceptable
anymore and we will call them out she
won't have to
valerie you were one of the co-signers
of that letter uh
what ex what exactly are you going to be
looking out for and what are you
challenging the media to do here
i think the question anthony is this are
you using language to describe
senator harris that you would not use to
describe a man i mean perfect example is
president
trump calling her mean angry and he's
done that not just with her but with
other women and that is not language
that is directed at men
questioning ambition i think ambition is
a good thing
what vice president hasn't been
ambitious what candidate running for
higher office isn't ambitious
yet when those words are directed
towards women they're pejorative and
that has to stop we do not need to have
a double standard
valerie jarrett thank you for being with
us this morning thanks so much